Spider-Man: Far From Home is blowing people
away at the box office.
And the latest hit from Marvel Studios is
chock full of inside references and Easter
Eggs that even the most hardcore fan might
miss.
Here's a spoiler-filled look at some small
details you may have missed in Spider-Man:
Far From Home.
In a cute running subplot throughout Far From
Home, Peter's man in the chair and all around
best buddy Ned Leeds has a whirlwind relationship
with Betty Brant, one of the other students
on their school trip to Europe.
They fall for each other on the flight across
the Atlantic, become a couple, and then break
up on the return trip.
It's funny and cute.
"that reminds me when I first fell in love.
I had just finished my fruit cobbler…"
Funny and cute, though, are two adjectives
fans never would have applied to the relationship
between Ned and Betty in the comics.
Originally one of Peter's love interests,
Betty Brant ended up marrying Ned Leeds, who
in the comics was an older reporter at the
Daily Bugle where the two worked.
The marriage was difficult, with multiple
separations and affairs.
Like their movie counterparts, the relationship
ended in Europe, but under very different
circumstances: set up as a scapegoat for the
crimes of the supervillain known as The Hobgoblin,
Ned was murdered by assassins in Berlin, leaving
Betty a widow.
Yikes!
One of the main plotlines in Far From Home
is Peter Parker's crush on fellow student
MJ.
He has a whole plan laid out to tell her how
he feels, only things keep getting in the
way — things like, for instance, supervillain
attacks.
"I had this plan with this girl that I really
like, and now it's all ruined."
But there's one other stumbling block: Brad
Davis, another schoolmate who also is romantically
interested in MJ, and who will do anything
in his power to stop his rival.
So it will come as no surprise that Brad — played
by Remy Hii — is actually straight out of
the comics.
Well, one comic anyway: Amazing Spider-Man
#188.
During a period where Peter and MJ were on
a break from their on-again-off-again relationship,
MJ brought star college quarterback Brad as
her date to a group outing, leading to a lot
of awkwardness.
It didn't last, though: after that one story,
Brad was never seen or heard from again.
Until now.
Spider-man's classic black costume is famous
among comic book fans and moviegoers alike,
as the alien symbiote suit was featured in
both Sam Raimi's 2007 film Spider-Man 3 and
the 2018 smash hit Venom.
But the new black suit Spidey wears in Far
From Home also has its own secret past in
the comics.
In the 2004 series Secret War, Nick Fury recruits
Spidey to help on a secret mission in Europe
and gives him a special black stealth suit
— which is exactly what happens in Far From
Home as well.
Now if only we can get that eagerly awaited
Night Monkey spinoff movie...
During Peter's initial meeting with Jake Gyllenhaal's
Quentin Beck, aka Mysterio, the supposed superhero
spins a story claiming to be from an alternate
reality where Earth's heroes failed and the
world was destroyed.
In what initially seems like a random word
salad, Mysterio says that the MCU version
of Earth is actually designated Earth-616,
while his alternate reality has the designation
Earth-833.
Fans of DC's Arrowverse shows on the CW may
recognize this as a joke about all the various
alternate Earths in the DC Multiverse, which
are given designations like Earth-1, Earth-2,
Earth-37, and so forth.
"Things must be different here."
"Barry, where's there?"
"My Earth.
Earth-90!"
And that's totally true, but this particular
joke actually originated in Marvel's Captain
Britain series from the 1980s.
The gag was that the Marvel Universe was Earth-616
because it isn't any more or less important
than any other universe.
And the 833 designation is far from random
either.
In the comics, Earth-833 was indeed destroyed,
and the only survivor was… an alternate-reality
version of Spider-Man.
Hmm!
At the very end of Far From Home, the final
post-credits scene revealed that Nick Fury
was actually Talos, the Skrull leader from
Captain Marvel.
Meanwhile, the real Fury is vacationing on
a beach which turns out to be just a holographic
projection on a spaceship.
"bwaaaaah!
BWAAAAH!"
The real Easter egg here, though, isn't the
Skrulls at all, it's the fake beach.
Fans of Marvel's Agents of SHIELD may recognize
this sequence as a nod to Project TAHITI.
After Agent Coulson died in Avengers, he was
brought back using the blood of a Kree, the
sworn enemies of the Skrull.
SHIELD then implanted fake memories in Coulson
so he thought he had been recuperating on
a beach in Tahiti just like Fury.
Well played, Marvel!
At the beginning of Spider-Man: Far From Home,
Spidey joins Aunt May for a charity event
aimed at helping people who have been displaced
after returning to existence during the events
of Avengers: Endgame.
Spidey has an awkward press conference, there's
a cute exchange between Aunt May, Happy Hogan,
and a gigantic novelty check -- it's fun.
It's also a big nod to the comics, where Aunt
May also runs a charity called FEAST.
FEAST first appeared in the comics in 2008's
Amazing Spider-Man #546, before making a prominent
appearance in the 2018 Playstation game Spider-Man.
Cool!
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
superheroes are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.